En 1950, on rencontrait son amoureux via les amis,
la famille ou pendant ses études.
Dans les années 90 arrivent les bars et le travail,
mais les amis restent indétrônables avec 35% des couples.
Sauf que depuis les années 2010, tout a changé.
Suivant les pays, c'est jusqu'à 40% des couples
qui se rencontrent sur internet.
Les sites et applis de rencontres y sont pour beaucoup.
Si vous avez moins de 30 ans, il y a une chance sur deux que vous les
ayez utilisés, mais pourquoi est-ce que ça marche si bien? Comment
fonctionne l'algorithme? Quels sont les profils qui plaisent
le plus? Et surtout, pourquoi autant de gens
semblent les détester mais continuent de les utiliser quand même?
Aujourd'hui, on vous amène découvrir la science derrière les
sites de rencontre.
L'amour sur internet marche-t-il aussi bien que dans la vraie vie?
En 2013, une étude prouve que les couples internet se marient
plus vite, divorcent moins et sont plus satisfaits.
Vraiment?! Contrairement à ce qu'on pense, trouver l'amour informatiquement,
ça ne date pas d'hier.
La première à avoir essayé c'était Johan Ball
en 1964.
A l'époque quasiment personne n'avait d'ordinateur chez lui.
Les gens remplissaient des questionnaires papiers puis un algorithme
les analysait.
Ensuite on envoyait les résultats par la poste et les gens se
débrouillaient.
Et ça marche! Les premiers couples formés grâce à
un algorithme ont 60 ans.
Rien d'étonnant si ça fonctionne aussi bien, mais pas pour les raisons
que vous pensez.
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé que quelqu'un vous raconte des trucs
super personnels alors que vous vous connaissez pas tant que ça
Ou même de vous dire: mais pourquoi je lui ai dit ça?
C'est
normal, se confier à des inconnus, c'est facile,
ils ne sont pas concernés directement par vos problèmes
et vous n'avez pas besoin de vous inquiéter des conséquences
de vos confidences.
C'est pour ça, par exemple, que les gens qui ont peur du rejet
ont plus de facilité à se livrer et être honnête en ligne.
L'anonymat, le temps de préparer ses réponses mais aussi
l'absence de signaux comme l'expression du visage ou l'intonation
de la voix, tout ça participe à faire tomber des barrières
sociales et vous encourage à vous ouvrir plus facilement.
Pourquoi c'est important? Parce que révéler des informations personnelles,
c'est un des premiers moyens de créer des liens.
Si quelqu'un s'ouvre à vous, naturellement vous avez envie
de lui faire confiance et de révéler des choses à votre tour.
Plus vous partagez des choses intimes avec quelqu'un, plus vous
renforcez le lien qui vous unit.
Se livrer aux autres a de vrais effets bénéfiques que la
science a pu prouver.
Combattre le stress, les émotions négatives, mieux contrôler
vos muscles cardiaques et même renforcer votre système
immunitaire.
Il y a aussi des avantages purement pratiques.
Dans la directive, c'est compliqué de rencontrer de nouvelles personnes.
Encore plus si vous êtes une minorité.
L'appli qui a propulsé le système de géolocalisation, c'est
Grindr, en 2009.
Aux USA, c'est un quart des couples LGBT qui
se rencontrent en ligne.
On est naturellement attiré par des gens qui nous ressemblent.
Si vous avez fait les mêmes études supérieures, vos chances de matcher
augmentent de 38%.
64% si vous avez tous les deux fréquenté une université
renommée, jusqu'à 97% si
vous avez la même religion ou encore 9%
si vous avez le même type de téléphone ou les
mêmes initiales.
Il y a même des sites de rencontre pour propriétaires de
Tesla, Tesla dating.
La seule exception c'est les introvertis qui ne matchent pas
très bien entre eux.
Ça va encore plus loin.
Une autre étude a présenté à des personnes des photos de
leurs conjoints où une certaine partie de leur visage ont été
remplacées par d'autres.
Résultat, les visages jugés les plus attirants sont toujours
ceux mixés avec des parties de la personne qui jugent.
Et ça marche aussi avec des caractéristiques physiques
des parents.
Et ça, jusqu'à un quart du visage remplacé.
Évidemment, il y a une limite, on ne cherche pas des copies de nous-mêmes.
D'ailleurs, on pourrait penser qu'à cause de ça, les sites
de rencontres empêchent la mixité sociale, mais pas
du tout.
En France, on est autour de 15% de couples mixtes,
plus 3% depuis 10 ans.
Aux USA, ils frôlent les 20%.
Et ce ratio est généralement plus élevé chez les couples
qui se rencontrent en ligne.
Car l'autre avantage des sites de rencontre, c'est la
qualité de profil que vous croisez.
Rencontrer plus de gens, c'est augmenter les chances de trouver
quelqu'un qui vous correspond.
Dans ce domaine, difficile de les battre.
Mais pour ça, il faut que les autres s'intéressent à vous.
Comment avoir le meilleur profil? Sur les applis, on
est tous égaux.
L'attractivité de votre profil n'a rien d'aléatoire.
On peut même noter votre désirabilité en
regardant par exemple combien de personnes choisissent votre
profil.
Disons que si 30 personnes sur 100 matchent avec vous,
vous avez un niveau de désirabilité de 3.
Une fois qu'on a ça, on est capable de prédire les réactions
des gens.
Par exemple ceux avec une note élevée sont non seulement choisis
plus souvent, mais aussi plus rapidement que les autres.
Au contraire, les notes basses sont souvent rejetées rapidement,
et ceux qui les sélectionnent hésitent jusqu'à 5 fois
plus longtemps.
En plus, les hommes et les femmes ne se comportent pas de la même façon.
Par exemple, les femmes acceptent plus rapidement les profils
avec une note élevée, mais passent plus longtemps avant de
rejeter quelqu'un qui a une mauvaise note.
En moyenne les gens ont déjà pris leur décision au bout de 11 secondes,
ça signifie qu'on se base sur peu de critères pour faire son choix.
Et il y en a un qui est plus important que tous les autres,
c'est le physique.
C'est pas très étonnant même si on connaît tous le coup de la
fausse photo de profil.
Dans l'esprit des gens, c'est plus difficile de mentir sur
une photo que dans une description.
Impossible de vérifier si vous êtes vraiment milliardaire, par
contre votre visage...
Le deuxième critère c'est le niveau d'étude, surtout important
pour ceux qui ont des diplômes.
Puis derrière tout le reste, par exemple, le contenu de votre
description.
Alors là, vous vous demandez, du coup, si je suis
moche, j'ai aucune chance Pas du tout.
Une photo attirante, c'est pas le cliché que vous vous en faites.
Genre une mâchoire carrée chez les mecs ou des jambes fines chez
les filles, ce qui compte le plus dans une photo, c'est l'image
que vous renvoyez.
Par exemple, les hommes sont jugés plus attirants quand ils ont l'air
d'avoir de l'assurance, d'être authentique et extraverti.
Les femmes, quant à elles, ont l'air d'être sûres d'elles,
tournées vers les autres.
Et montrer un côté féminin rend tout le monde plus attirant,
indépendamment du genre.
Regardez ces deux photos de moi, le vrai secret c'est
d'avoir confiance en soi.
Et ça se ressent partout.
On a demandé à des femmes de juger l'attractivité de textes
de présentation et de photos indépendamment l'un
de l'autre, et les gens attirés en photo le
sont aussi par écrit.
Le pire, c'est que les gens en ont conscience.
Ceux jugés pas attirants ont plus tendance à mentir
sur leur description ou retoucher les photos pour compenser.
Et les sédisants ont plus souvent envie de tromper leur
partenaire.
Mais attention, tout se résume pas à la photo et à la description.
Le premier choix sert juste à faire le tri.
C'est en message privé que vous cherchez inconsciemment des
points communs avec l'autre, que vous échangez sur votre vie
privée ou que vous le bloquez parce qu'il dit des trucs bizarres.
Alors comment faire pour optimiser vos chances de passer la première
phase de sélection. D'abord, identifiez vos qualités.
Listez les choses que vous aimez, demandez-vous ce que les
autres apprécient chez vous.
Ensuite choisissez des photos que vous aimez bien et qui vous
représentent.
Évitez à tout prix de tomber dans la photo cliché,
si vous vous mettez en scène, ça va se voir et vous vous
faites sûrement une fausse idée de ce que les gens recherchent.
L'idéal c'est une photo prise pour une autre occasion où vous
souriez et où on voit que vous êtes sociable.
Pour les textes libres, ne vous prenez pas trop la tête, la plupart
des gens les lisent en diagonale.
Donnez juste des infos importantes, genre le type
de relation que vous recherchez, évitez juste les fautes,
quand quelqu'un les repère, ça impacte très négativement
son jugement.
Les QCMs ou les cases info à remplir n'ont souvent
aucun impact sur l'attirance de votre profil.
Les gens s'en servent juste pour vérifier qu'il n'y a pas un truc
éliminatoire chez vous.
Mais avant ça, il y a encore un élément en travers de votre
route, l'appli elle-même.
La science des algorithmes.
Est-ce que vous savez que vous pouvez demander l'intégralité de
vos données au site de rencontre. Toutes collectent des millions d'informations
sur vous et vous laissent les récupérer.
Un petit formulaire à remplir pour retrouver des centaines
de pages de secrets comme l'historique honteux de
vos messages de jeunesse.
Toutes ces données, ils en ont besoin pour faire tourner leur algorithme.
A une époque par exemple, on sait que Tinder utilisait
un système d'elo.
Oui, le même système de classement qu'aux échecs ou dans les jeux vidéo.
Quand vous aviez des matchs, vous grimpiez dans le classement des gens
séduisants.
A l'inverse, si tout le monde vous envoyait balader, vous finissiez en bas.
Mais aujourd'hui, le système a évolué.
Il utilise un système de compatibilité.
L'algorithme note quel profil vous avez aimé, quel type
de personnes ont aimé le vôtre et enfin avec qui
vous avez matché.
Puis il va regarder les autres utilisateurs qui ont des goûts
similaires au vôtre.
Par exemple, si vous avez exactement les mêmes goûts que Jérôme,
qui lui a eu un match avec Christine, il va aussi
vous la présenter.
Plusieurs applis revendiquent carrément l'utilisation de l'algorithme
Gale-Chaplet récompensé d'un prix Nobel.
On prouve que pour un nombre donné d'hommes et de femmes, on
peut toujours trouver une manière de les mettre en couple
qui convienne à tout le monde.
Mais pour ça, en plus de se baser sur les préférences, on
doit aussi multiplier les propositions.
Du coup, le meilleur moyen de tirer parti de l'algorithme, c'est
d'utiliser l'application.
A force, il va cerner ceux qui vous plaît et optimiser vos
chances de rencontrer quelqu'un.
La plupart des applis avec un swipe utilisent un système similaire.
Ça marche bien, mais il y a quand même des petits problèmes.
Si vous ne savez pas trop ce que vous cherchez, ou si vous choisissez
des profils un peu au hasard, vous pouvez vite vous retrouver
dans une boucle qui ne vous correspond pas.
Ensuite, à force de voir des profils qui sont censés vous plaire,
vous allez peut-être passer à côté de gens géniaux mais
différents de ceux que vous rencontrez habituellement.
De l'autre côté, ça veut aussi dire qu'une fois que l'algo vous a cerné,
il propose en premier les profils qui ont le plus de chances de
vous plaire.
Alors à chaque fois qu'on vous dit non, la personne suivante est
une moins bonne option que la précédente.
C'est pour ça que certaines applications utilisent des systèmes différents.
Grindr par exemple présente en priorité les gens
qui sont actifs et proches de vous et mélange ça avec
quelques profils aléatoires.
Il y a aussi les questionnaires.
On trouve ça plutôt sur les sites web comme e-harmony
ou okcupid.
Ça a quelques défauts comme le fait que les gens ne savent
pas toujours ce qu'ils recherchent ou au contraire qu'ils sont
sûrs d'eux mais se concentrent que sur des éléments qui
ne permettent pas de savoir s'ils vont s'entendre avec l'autre,
comme la taille ou les revenus.
Mais globalement ça marche plutôt bien parce qu'en fait
les algorithmes n'ont pas besoin de fonctionner pour être utiles.
Le simple fait que le site ou l'appli vous propose quelqu'un,
peu importe que j'ai raison ou non, ça augmente les chances que
votre premier date se passe bien.
Comme quand votre famille ou vos amis vous disent qu'ils aiment bien votre
partenaire, ça booste votre confiance et votre
sentiment d'avoir fait un bon choix.
Ça se combine avec l'effet de halo naturellement présent
sur ces sites.
Le fait que si votre première impression de quelqu'un est positive,
vous allez lui attribuer tout un tas d'autres qualités
inconsciemment.
Tout ça, ça fait que parfois, on matche avec des gens pour
de mauvaises raisons.
Les gens qui utilisent des applis de rencontre ont jusqu'à
16 fois plus de risques d'avoir des troubles de l'alimentation.
3,5 fois plus de risques d'être angoissé, ont
une moins bonne estime d'eux, se comparent plus souvent aux
autres ou encore ont plus peur de finir célibataire.
Et y'a pas forcément de lien avec le nombre de matchs.
Les études sont formelles, plus vous passez de temps à regarder
les profils, plus vous êtes malheureux et plus vous rejetez les gens.
Sur certains sites, c'est jusqu'à 75% des
utilisateurs qui sont épuisés.
Ca peut être dû au rejet répété qui donne le sentiment
que personne ne s'intéresse à vous.
Un phénomène que ressentent environ 65%
des hommes et 40% des femmes.
Mais aussi au fait d'avoir trop de succès, car ce qui
a le plus d'impact c'est la surabondance des choix.
Plus vous avez d'options, plus c'est difficile d'être sûr de soi.
Est-ce que vous parlez à la bonne personne? L'autre profil
était peut-être mieux.
Et si vous aviez raté la chance de votre vie? Ça donne lieu
à une dissonance cognitive.
Impossible de savoir si vous avez pris la bonne décision.
Mais les sites de rencontre ont un autre problème.
Si ça permet aux gens de s'ouvrir plus facilement, l'anonymat
a aussi des dérives.
Par exemple, un tas de personnes les utilisent alors qu'ils
sont déjà en relation, sans vous prévenir bien sûr.
Rien que sur Tinder, on parle de 18 à
25 % suivant les études.
Difficile de donner sa confiance dans ces conditions.
Certains sites sont carrément spécialisés dans l'adultère.
Mais c'est rien à côté des comportements ouvertement toxiques
et là, malheureusement, les premières victimes ce sont les
femmes.
Presque 60% des 18-34 ans disent avoir
reçu des photos explicites sans rien avoir demandé.
44% se sont déjà fait insulter et 19%
ont été menacés de violences.
Ou encore les types qui vous retrouvent sur Insta grâce à votre nom
pour continuer de vous écrire.
Et ça, sans parler des arnaques, des mensonges ou même
des guet-apens des types qui flirtent avec vous sur le site,
vous donnent rendez-vous, puis une fois sur place, vous font
les poches, vous tabassent ou pire.
On est obligé de développer des outils pour y faire face,
des IA anti-dickpick comme celle de Bumble,
qui analysent les messages pour bloquer les contenus problématiques,
ou carrément, créent des applis qui laissent les femmes
décider si elles veulent parler ou non.
Tout ça, ça n'aide pas à combattre les clichés, surtout quand ils sont
validés par les statistiques.
Oui, les hommes cherchent généralement des relations plus courtes que les femmes,
écrivent plus de messages, reçoivent moins de réponses
et accordent plus d'importance à l'aspect physique.
Mais est-ce que malgré ces défauts, on a vraiment une raison de
s'y opposer? Ça fait bientôt 10 ans que le moyen le plus commun
de rencontrer un partenaire, c'est sur internet.
Et même quand vous flashez sur des gens en soirée ou via des amis,
ça vous empêche pas de juger le physique, de tomber
sur des types bizarres et une fois rentré chez vous, de
faire connaissance par SMS.
Maintenant qu'on a fait le tour, vous pouvez raconter vos meilleures
et vos pires histoires en commentaire.
Promis, on juge pas.